thank you for joining us my name is
Andrew Fulton I have a pH Psychology
from Wabash College and currently I'm a
senior software engineer at quantite
hi my name is Ani I have a bachelor's in
physics and a bachelor's in computer
science from Louisville University in
Chicago I'm currently in a software
engineer at one sec
and I'm Adam Lewis I also I'm a software
engineer at quantite I'm a bachelor's in
PhD in chemical engineering for BYU and
UT Austin
and
um we as we mentioned where we work at
Quan site and so Quan site's mission is
to enable a robust open source data
economy
and we do this by providing Consulting
and development services to clients to
any corporate funding for open source
communities and managing early stage
investments in businesses that include
the Outsource software so managing those
Investments directly as well
so the work that we're going to present
today came out of that first point
providing Consulting and development
services for one of our clients RBC
which is one of the world's largest
banks
and we want to thank them for bringing
this on and giving us the opportunity to
collaborate with them they have a lot of
talented Engineers that we work closely
with to come up with a lot of the ideas
that we're presenting today and they're
committed to maintaining the modern data
processing sex to solve large data
patterns which has made them a pleasure
to work with
so here's the actual problem that we
were working on
um you can see that we have uh and
through this talk we're gonna we're
gonna take you through the Journey of
deploying an open source large-scale
data processing pipeline for running
valuation adjustment models for models
that quantify risk for the bank and so
here you can see some of the data that
we had it had three columns path date
and value each of those paths is a this
comes from Monte Carlo simulation so
each of those paths is a simulation we
are you know projecting these
simulations out into the future that's
the date column and the value is
represents risk so we have 50 000 paths
120 dates for each of those paths so six
million rows for each of these files
each file is about 140 megabytes we had
140 000 files so it's about 20 terabytes
of data total and so each of these files
are groups together in Risk groups and
of course we and we're basically doing
just a large sum to pre-process this
data for these risk models
and so of course we want to do this
activation as quickly as possible
so the uh it's a little more complex
than I that I said on the previous slide
so here's a little bit more detail each
of these groups as you can see is
anywhere from 18 000 files to two files
and one of some each of these groups up
and additionally there's a few layers of
grouping so there's first layer grouping
of these stacks and files but then we
also want to some groups of those Stacks
which are these red rectangles and then
further we want to uh some groups of
these groups of stacks and files so
there's several layers of these risk
groups file groups basically yeah we're
doing a sum of these various segmented
portions of our of our data
so let me look at approaching this
problem and trying to speed up this
computational model initially we looked
at the variety of different things that
we could we could do here we looked at
Harbor options and we basically looked
at if we shifted
compute or compute power from our CPU to
the gtu we looked at how we can use gas
with particularly all the different fast
apis in order to achieve support some
aggregation speedups and finally we
looked at productionizing this entire
engine using a workflow tool the problem
with workflow tools and using just tasks
by itself is that it's really difficult
for people to Just Launch jobs in this
cluster with very little recognitions
and these workflow tools enable us to do
that properly really but first we'll
take a look at how we looked at gpus and
CPUs and saw exactly what we did in
order to implement this kind of change
first we realized that something using
the GPU makes a lot of sense we're
effectively writing the same kind of
operation across a different element
that's set to a thread in our Nvidia or
GPU of choice second we were trying to
reduce i o bottlenecks specifically
networking bottlenecks that we were
facing at that time and we wondered if
we could compute that stuff if we could
make up for that time and kind of reduce
the i o bottlenecking from doing things
like pushing and pulling from the cloud
which unfortunately take a lot of time
and finally we looked at how we could
optimize our for loops when we were
looking at when we were looking at how
to implement these matrices inside these
gpus and represent them we realized that
normal for looping was going to get us
actually pretty far we just needed to
optimize the heck out of the for Loops
so we decided to do all of this and we
were honestly Guided by the Nvidia Cuda
environment and the process and
structure that's set up around there I
did want to give a shout out to amd's
rock m Open Source environment they've
done a lot of job they've done a really
good job trying to get the python
Community involved and trying to make
open source GPU compute uh one kind of
like pipeline fits all kind of thing but
unfortunately Nvidia Cuda just went out
because
quite frankly the support that Cuda
offers programmers is far more suited
towards Enterprise environments
so when we look at the GPU ecosystem
around late 2020 early 2021 we looked at
all the libraries that kind of used a
GPU compute engine as their back end
first we looked at the rapid stack and
the rapid stack as a team that actually
works out of Nvidia and they provided a
great set of libraries in the open
source ecosystem to enable python to
enable python programmers and using a
python API to use Cuda directly we also
looked at other options such as pipe
torch and tensorflow these libraries
while initially looked at as possible
solutions and not not being the solution
that we were looking for tensorflow was
not as popular at the time so we decided
to Instead try doing these kinds of
simulations using pi torch the problem
that we've heard with pytorch is that
the models that Pi torch demanded were
suited much more towards machine
learning problem sets and not really the
prop set that we were trying to solve a
simple summation and aggregation so we
decided that Pine torch didn't really
have the low level API that we were
looking for in order to interact with
our data we then looked at the rapid
stack and all of the tools and libraries
they've provided underneath the rapid
stack they used to have plays in SQL and
they still have kudi F and Coupe and a
bunch of other libraries that mimic the
pi data stack but just for the GPU
back-end computing
blazing SQL at the time was a SQL engine
where we could write SQL queries compile
them to our GPU and it would be the same
kind of objects that we'd use in qdf
however as a current date blazing SQL
has since been deprecated and now you
can use task SQL instead and it just
ships with desks to run these same SQL
queries we also decided to look at heavy
Ai and heavy.ai is to formally be known
as omnis ITV and this is an engine that
allows you to run SQL queries over their
gpus
however at the end of the day we decided
that unfortunately on the side couldn't
scale to the kind of performance levels
that we were expecting to scale to so we
ended up looking at PDF and non-vi and
seeing if we could generate some some
Kubota code from this directly
we decided to First Look at gpus in the
cloud because we had to get access to
our GPU somehow and this was actually
proving to be a little bit of a pain
at that point in time
um container container support for gpus
was just becoming a thing and so what we
decided to do is we decided to look at
what was the most used and easily
accessible way to pass gpus through from
bare metal to our hypervisor in this
case we ended up using the docker
container runtime but as of recently
there's also support for containerd to
allow GPU passes
but once we finally allow GPU pass
through into our images we were
questioning exactly how we would cut
these things up and kubernetes and when
deploying tasks and other games on
kubernetes there's multiple layers of
segmentation that happen to our system
so we were trying to figure out if say
two gpus in one pod which would maybe
relate to one worker would be an
efficient strategy
this was experimented and tested by us
several times and eventually we also
tested a multitude of other libraries
such as desk kudia to try to increase
our memory space available
we also had darker container hurdles
when trying to implement this kind of
work though specifically we had Rapids
image ranking conflicts that is we took
the original Rapids team provided image
and tried to layer other pack ETS on top
of there but we ran into problems that
that packages who were depending on
other packages had version conflicts so
we couldn't really get this to work at
the end of the day we ended up using
normal Docker putting on a uh using a
Ubuntu image and then installing mini
condom manually alongside the NVIDIA
drivers and actually sourcing them in
our environment such that we could have
successfully have an engine that runs
GPU
when working with all of these kinds of
libraries you kind of realize that
there's a pattern happening and the
pattern that I kind of realized uh came
and drilled down to this effectively
what you want to do is you want to look
at your metadata basically look at your
data type your data shape and see how
large it is then you want to make some
decisions regarding how you load data
onto your GPU even though we're using
python we still need to worry about
things like memory on the GPU we
literally need to allocate space on the
GPU and send our matrices to matrices
and other things over there so that
there's no compiler errors when we try
to run this kind of code so we have to
load our data and then we also have to
make sure that there's space for the
actual data that's being computed on on
the GP itself from there on you can then
choose your analysis tool of choice in
our case we chose Napa and
UDF but effectively any kind of GPU
bound python library and then run your
analysis on top of that
finally the most I owe uh the most IO
heavy part of this entire thing is
copying to the host the time spent
copying data from GPU to the host is a
lot and honestly might be the case as to
why we decided not to go with GPS
fun and then finally we needed to write
this data to object storage somehow so
we still we're not bypassing the i o
bottleneck right
right so we didn't put it up there and
get something written
so I wanted to take a look at some
presentations of how you use PDF which
in our videos to be a high level API and
how you can use years the one thing that
you'll see that people take a lot of
effort and Care into is that academics
the pandas API very very well and it's
literally a drop-in replacement so you
can see that that weed parquet call is
being called from pandas for kudia but
the actual drop approved by an
aggregation portions of it mimic the epi
this is what he found official because
it's a drop in replacement and while the
speed up is not that impressive there is
definitely a speed up however we decided
that this wasn't fast enough so we
decided to go a little lower and we
decided to use number in order to send
and write device currents and um send
them over to this GPU and calculate them
but here you'll see I've written some
pseudo code some examples to kind of
show and mimic uh exactly how we did
this and you'll see that our GPU time
for compute increased it's 0.336 seconds
great
well when I try to actually press enter
on the object it was like Hey I'm a kdf
cream I don't know what you want from me
and I realized it was because it was
still stuck on the GPU now when I tried
to copy that over to my host the i o
penalty that I incurred was 11 seconds
and at the end of the day we're actually
going slower than CPUs on gpus because
of the iot
now I wanted to note that there is a way
to uh to increase the performance and
increase that or decrease that time
consent but we didn't get there however
I've included some links written by
people over at the Rapids team at Nvidia
on how this problem can be addressed
all in all we learned that I O operation
for gpus
is really costly and sometimes could
make or break your decision to use that
we also learned that GPS are still
expensive if I'm going to a cloud vendor
and trying to spin up a GPU machine I
might be better off getting a machine
with 300 to 600 more vcpus and two point
something more terabytes of RAM for the
same price I would paid for at least it
GPU
and finally I wanted to say that the
python 2. ecosystem is awesome quite
frankly I've had a pleasure programming
the python Cuda ecosystem because
compared to some of the sequel plus boot
up production out there we were able to
experiment really darn quickly and even
though our number code looked a lot like
Z Plus at the end of the day the python
ecosystem really hides a lot of that
from the user and allows people that
might not have that Cuda knowledge to
get really into the ecosystem or attack
even if you have that Buddha knowledge
you have something like number that you
can still use those Cuda techniques with
so when going back to the problem we
realized that gpus were not going to
work so instead we looked at all the
ways in which we could deploy tasks and
employees and used to ask apis to get
significant speed up and for that I'll
let Andrew take it over
so for the next portion of our talk I
wanted to discuss our aggregation
strategies
let's say Simplicity I want you to focus
on what level of aggregation
rather than the nested aggregations
we're actually doing it has a recap of
the aggregation problem we add up to
1700 sets of files with each set ranging
from two to eighteen thousand files per
aggregation each file had up to 6
million rows in each row included date
path and value columns our goal was to
aggregate all the values by date and
path across all the files in the given
set and do this as quickly as possible
to sell recall we start off with a
simple Group by approach we would take a
list of parquet files and we would
simply pass that list to a Das data
frame to read parquet function we would
then run the group by Method on the
loaded data frame and take the song but
what if the data frame was larger than
the cluster itself
as it turns out that's an issue that we
ran into with some of our larger
aggregations
when we submitted jobs workers would be
forced to pause or restart when the
memory thresholds for the cluster were
reached causing the job to fail
you see on the on the slide here an
example is happening we try to aggregate
10 60 million row files on the gas
cluster with two workers each with four
gigabytes of memory and had a killed
Warfare
I will note however that in this example
I'm using an older version to ask and I
could not the promise since been
alleviated with improvements to the
scheduler and I was not able to
reproduce this Arrow this era on this
scale I'm testing here with the most
recent version of desk
um this was our son that we had to
address at the time
so in order to address this problem we
use the chunkings we use the chunking
strategy at the time we found that we
created a graph that chunks the group by
the smaller aggregations to schedule it
after easy time easier time pain related
to load this set this for a set of files
if the set of files met a specific
threshold 10 in this case we would build
a desk deskcraft a first load of subset
of the files group and aggregate the sub
stat and then brief subsequent subsets
that we reached the new set would be
concatenated with the previously
aggravated results and then the
resulting data frame would be grouped
and aggregated so whole files are
aggravated together
otherwise if there were not enough files
to either threshold we would just follow
the standard uh read parquet Group by
some strategy with this strategy we were
able to aggregate the the large
segregation sets but we still have a lot
of aggregations to do and we wanted to
run them as quickly as possible and so
that's where we started seeing our next
set of problems the strategy they out so
far allowed us to be able to complete
any of our aggregations on an individual
basis but when submitting the thousands
of Aggregates at that time some of those
larger than the cluster itself we again
ran into our original problem workers
were frequently running out of memory
and either positive or Worse getting
killed which caused a lot of work to be
duplicated or airing out completely
so to combat this we decide to throttle
how much work we were going to get this
guy by a time and to do this we employed
a thread pool at Scooter to this to
significant jobs and so this would allow
us to submit jobs at once but still
limit how much was getting submitted to
the scheduler each job would get a
thread worker and the job would hold a
place in the pool until it's complete in
which case the technical would go and
crap and the next job to submit but
we're still running across the
overloading and scheduling uh over on
cluster we could just lower the number
of threat workers but then we still had
jobs that were larger than the cluster
on an individual basis so we're still
overloading the cluster at times and the
rest of time clusterity highly
underutilized for core efficiency and
economy so instead of just lowering the
number of thread workers in our thread
pool we started checking the cluster
resources manually with the task
scheduler before submitting to make sure
there was space
this strategy gave us the benefit of
being able to increase the threshold
workers for federal cluster utilization
for smaller aggregations but I still
but it also a lot still allowed us to
throttle them out of submissions that we
did too
so for this to work we would set it up
so when the thread pool worker got a new
task we first estimate the required Max
resources the task of need such as just
the number of files multiplied by
estimated file size then we would
activate a thread lock so only one one
thread could check the
checking submitted time then we would
check cluster Resources with the code
above and if the resources are available
the task would be submitted to the Das
scheduler then there would be a brief
wait and thread locked wouldn't be
released so that other workers could
work
okay so we're getting closer we now have
a little more leeway to increase threat
for workers for better cluster
utilization but it's still taking time
to create the graphs in the first place
and we didn't have complete reliability
with our live park aggregations yet
let's remind me to create a second
thread collect speeder and this
threadblock speeder was responsible for
creating the dash graphs for each
aggregation group and then passing off
each Dash graph to the next threadful
for submission to the cluster with the
larger aggregation groups we found I
would submit them via the creation
thread pool when they were where they
would throttle the amount of new grass
can create the Creed cluster resources
free
so the upside of the strategy is that we
could we could reliably complete large
craft large batch of the tops and we'd
utilize the cluster fairly efficiently
efficiently on the other hand it was a
very tedious to two anytime resources
for the scale the job changed we'd have
to put in a quite a bit of work to
figure out how many threads we needed
how long to sleep when the locker
threats above and also the group I
shuffle the data between the nodes for
the pods was still very expensive and on
top of that we basically built the
scheduler on top of that scheduler which
is not generally what we want to do
so uh
so at this field at this point we
started feeling like we were running out
of Windows sales with our group by
multi-directed strategy is becoming
clear that our code was quite quite
complex and not very efficient and the
more we continue down this path the more
technical American accrue to begin to
think of other ways that we could add
the data at this point we realized that
painted data frames actually sung
together quite nicely
pandas ensures that the index and the
columns match up so that you won't end
up with invalid data and it's much
faster than a group buy another bonus is
that by moving out a dash data frame we
utilize multi-index sync which helps cut
down on the memory footprint as well
our days at Sunny are real X data frames
was about three times faster than
running a group by on a concatenated
data frame
we're still having a little bit of
trouble getting data frames at the right
place at the right time though we want
to keep the different aggregation groups
more separated
so that for the majority of GA or for
aggregations work would stay on a single
node that's when we start looking at
cluster clusters and for this I'll adapt
to go
so yeah one of the keynote uh talks at
the desk Summit in May 2021 talked about
using a Das cluster of gas clusters so
we decided to try it out there's kind of
the architecture over on the right hand
side of what I'm what I mean
so that large outer rectangle is the
outer desk cluster clusters
and of course you have a scheduler and
then your desk workers but then within
each of those three Das workers you have
a you start up a desk local cluster so
you're able to send kind of larger tasks
to each task worker and then on the
local cluster we parallelize over that
larger task and process it
uh this gave us the benefit of reducing
the number of clients communicating with
any desk scheduler introduces Network
traffic and helped us get around some
some network issues that we were seeing
um and then I'll talk about a little bit
later however we still required the
thread pull that Andrew talked about and
tuning the manual tuning of the
parameter to that thread pool in order
to prevent running out of memory of some
of the larger aggregations and so we
looked into desk bag afterwards to try
to get around these thread pool manual
tuning compared
all right so let's return the navigation
here so sum up where we are at this
point we moved away from free-for-all
clusters drive to employ a cluster
cluster strategy we've changed how we
were doing our aggregations from a group
by to a data frame substance strategy
we're seeing a lot of improvements but
we felt like there were more
optimization to be made particularly how
the aggregations were being done for
example we're not happy with the amount
of code necessary to limit Network
traffic between our low cluster workers
and on top that we're still dealing with
threat rule which seemed like a lot of
unnecessary complexity to our code so
this is when we started looking more
seriously to death back best bag is
typically used for processing text or
Json files so it's probably not the
first thing people think of when they
need to work with data frames but one of
the biggest advantages is that follows
the mapreduce model it allows us to take
a more hands-off approach because we can
contrast that it will reduce our data on
each individual worker as much as
possible before moving data between
workers to finish segregations here you
can see we start by passing in a
sequence of file paths to from sequence
we also Define the partition size which
is the number of units included in each
reduction so here we have it set to five
five files next we use we map load data
frame to our sequence of file pass and
finally we summon and we submit this
this code task will send batch of the
files defined by the partition size to
the workers the workers will then apply
the mappings of the aggregation to each
batch and then re-partition and apply
the mappings and aggregation onto the
new batches until the data set is fully
aggregated
we also started utilizing uh resource
annotations
these gave us big hand up by letting us
take a more hands-off approach to the
scheduler instead of managing how much
work we're submitting manually we could
submit it all end up the schedule let
the scheduler do all the heavy lifting
of managing resources so annotating your
dashcraft is pretty easy uh first thing
you set up your your cluster by
configuring the necessary resources as
you can see the code on the screen we
use the context manager desktop config
to set the memory resources to this
cluster to 77 500 megabytes uh the
resource name and the value can be set
arbitrarily for example I could have set
the resource to be widget instead of
memory and it wouldn't all work the same
as long as they're consistent between
your cluster configuration and your in
your annotations
mixing and take your desk objects in the
code in the above code you can see that
I entered the blocks of desk objects
with the max amount of memory I expected
need and so now when I run these the
schedule knows not to send off the block
to to work to a worker until there are
necessary resources available on the
cluster so utilizing this really
let us take much more Hands-On approach
to about the task scheduler do a lot of
work which really set up our
aggregations a lot
it's now that Adam take over to discuss
the orchestration of these jobs
so at this point we have a workable
solution to aggregate all those files
that I mentioned uh but as so we start
looking into moving this into production
we start worrying more about reliability
logging visualization and so we we
looked at uh prefix to do this so
prefect if any of you don't know is a
data workflow orchestration tool we
specifically were using version one of
prefix there's uh since has been
released to version two it was invaded
at the time we didn't use version two
but anyway if we use version one uh just
give it very kind of brief background on
jargon uh in the prefect uh python
package so there's the idea of a task
and I think of it as just a python
function that's what a task is and then
there's a flow which is a collection of
tasks and then some flow control logic
uh that between the tasks
and then also there's the prefect cloud
or prefix server exists we've got cloud
is a commercial version uh offered by
prefect and prefect service and open
source version
as well as the community and then uh
prefect Cloud premix server they both
run flows in response to triggers and
scale
and skid logging and provide a
visualization dashboard a lot of those
things that we're looking for in our
production production solution and
additionally prefect integrates nicely
adapts to run each task on a desk
cluster so that's what so the reason why
we we're considered prefect
so we set up our computation like this
um we set up each of our high level each
of our high level file groups to be
aggregated in its own below and then
each of those sub groupings we aggregate
in individual prefect tasks
and unfortunately what we saw when we
did this is we had some issues
overloading the desk scheduler so we had
many many tasks thousands of tasks
running simultaneously and each prefect
task created a client connecting to the
Das cluster so the two issues that we
saw is first there were too many file
scriptures open on the desk scheduling
too many network connections it's a it's
a known issue in desk and there's a
there's a solution you can increase the
U limit and you can get around that so
we were able to get around this too many
file descriptors on the desk scheduler
however we also saw that our task
workers were started timing out waiting
for a response from the schedule we have
so many clients connecting to that
scheduler scheduler didn't get around to
contacting each of its workers at a time
um and so the workers thought I was
scheduler must be dead they
um again there's there's desk
configuration we could probably edit to
get around that
um but we We additionally saw another
issue as well
um and so prefix server uh we're running
it as I said thousands and thousands of
tasks simultaneously prefix servers the
open source versions it's good for a lot
of things good for a lot of use cases
however we saw that about Beyond about a
thousand simultaneous tasks being run it
was necessary to start scaling up the
individual components of the
microservice the the original
microservices the makeup prefix server
so there's a graphql microservices and
post-dressing microservice and now it's
going to require a lot of effort on our
parts to do that and to be fair prefect
Cloud right that's a commercial version
it handles all that for you and so um
you know that might that wouldn't have
been an issue for us but we using
prefect Cloud wasn't an option for us
with this client so because of these
issues that we were seeing we decided to
look into other Alternatives and namely
we looked into Argo workflows which is
tightly integrated with kubernetes and
it's it's another open source workflow
engine for orchestrating parallel jobs
specifically on kubernetes so we used a
lot of this the ideas that we've already
mentioned like the Das cluster clusters
but we could have replaced that outer
gas cluster with Argo workflows so you
can see there our doors closed kind of
takes up that place and then sends each
of the file aggregations to workflow
pods
and that gave us a few benefits
so it allowed us to simplify this SAS
communication get around those those
issues that I had mentioned but also we
still get a lot of those
production-based production benefits it
still captures the logs from each of
those workflows you also provide a
visualization still provides
visualization dashboard and some retry
logic if any of your workflow pods fail
and additionally we on each of those
workflow pods we can still spin up that
Das local cluster and use desk back to
control the resource usage within each
of those individual workflow pods and
then some of those aggregations
individual aggregations were still large
enough to exceed the memory on the
workflow pod and so in those cases we
did spin up an external desk scheduler
to handle those aggregations but it's
still a lot more limited in scope and it
did end up moving our needs and
for us so in conclusion we looked into
GPU use for our problem but we found
that after accounting for the data
transfer they can give us a speed up in
this particular use case or at least not
enough of a speed up to justify the
additional cost and we also use desk in
various configurations to accomplish the
large-scale aggregation that we needed
and then finally we investigated the use
of open the open source prefix server
but we settled on using Arbor workflows
to achieve that goal of deploying an
open source large-scale data processing
pipeline running for preparing the data
for these risk models used by our client
all right thanks uh for listening and
what questions do you all have
[Applause]
this did you feel that uh I mean it
sounds like you know the problem when
you originally stated it sounds simple
but then obviously your solution looks
uh quite complex in the end was part of
the issue do you think the way that the
data was stored uh the kind of the input
as you were given it was that part of
what made it challenging
to some extent I I
think we we tested a couple different
file types and RK ended up being faster
especially when it was in that the
column nerve format
um we did play around with pivoting the
table so that uh the data was stored
where the paths were indexed and columns
were the dates those some a lot faster
but uh
but there's they're a lot slower to read
right the i o end up in one of our major
automats for us
what if the files were set up by date so
you kind of like read in
you create directories per day and then
put the data in there for the day so you
kind of
create a hierarchical data set
based on the way you need to group it
yeah one of the constraints for us is
that the data that's coming to us is in
the format kind of initially shown and
so you know perhaps if there was a
you've done kind of an intermediate
transformation step to get into that
that you know potentially important as
well
but for us we were you know handed the
data in that format we were constrained
to using it's starting with it now
[Music]
all right so this is a very valued
question
so your task was
given a certain set of
parameters add up a bunch of numbers
is that right
yeah and so in a simplified sense yeah
well that's what I said the question is
could you have just spent a month in
computed all possible outputs for all
possible inputs and then just had a
giant hookup tape
um
evaluations and they wanted them kind of
in real time and the numbers are always
changing well that's that's so that's
it's not like you can just do it once
yeah once and you're done forever it's
like someone needs to make a decision
prison meal time and if you're like you
know 10 minutes too late you know if
you're 10 minutes too late yeah yeah so
yes
[Music]
so a prefix server that has is an open
source uh product uh so what we found is
that there's a lot of communication
between each of these uh
individual flows that we're running and
the kind of the components that keep
track of the logs that you showed this
current status or anything there's a lot
of communication happening so we just it
needed to be scaled up further and so
I'm not saying it's impossible to do
right and prefect uh Cloud presumably
just does just that like scales these up
for you however it was going to take
quite a bit effort on our part to do
that so so it kind of naturally trying
to
provide value you know quickly and
easily we're looking at Alternatives
that we considered Alternatives as well
to try to get around that issue we
didn't see the same limitations
so with VL after all this work uh what
kind of performance did you get
we could run the 18th the 1700
aggregations with about 140 000 total in
about 13 minutes it's been 13 months
yeah and what kind of Hardware are you
doing uh we were using uh 20 of these
are the largest CPU
look memory memory uh
optimize optimized machines
so I'm curious now like uh this is a
simulation meaning that you probably
like in theory you could choose how how
many simulations you do so when they're
like in the middle like if you guys
obviously spend a lot of effort but in
the Middle where you had some roadblock
have you ever uh have you ever talked
with the business requirement and often
like uh do we want to do it last so is
this to negotiate negotiable or is it
like a hard requirement that you guys
have to do that amount of simulations
for
transfer it was a pretty hard
requirement I mean we we definitely did
lots of simulations with us
or lots of uh trials for plus
simulations but the goal is to meet
you guys know that Bitcoin solves this
all right like just going to the banks
yes yep so 215
four gigs
the second
do you ever explore like something like
that to the ladies or something
yeah yeah
and our energy the notes that we ended
up with are much much larger than
um the ones that we were initially
testing with and you mentioned we used
to have the largest memory optimized
nodes on
us and they're pretty beefy
um and we also did a lot of work in
terms of desk worker optimization the
dust kubernetes ensuring that the spec
for the pots and workers were
effectively
all that kind of stuff yes the code
Snippets were just examples trying to
show the same issues that we saw but not
actually our production we were using
more
yes if you were going to do this
yeah I think so um
I really like that it's all in Python I
I find that a lot easier to work with
and you know we were always able to see
what the problem was pretty quickly
maybe not what was causing the problem
but what their problem was where when
I've worked with like iceberg in the
past I get these you know long whole
pages of
tray stacks of uh
Java that the office doesn't make much
sense today
yes can you consider
it's like a
that's a major problem and
some things separately and some of them
back up together if you consider just
taking
tables at a time and selling them in a
single mode
across 10 000 different notes so that
you can do pairwise and then slowly
build a tree so to speak of directory
yeah we did look we did look at doing
that but
the big for the big part of the promise
IO well I guess you get i o anyway
but also
yeah there's memory
um there it's moving stuff across
workers it's really expensive so if you
have a thousand workers you can plug two
files that means your work your head
moving 5 000 files and then 2500 miles
which gets really expensive so we wanted
to do it we wanted to do it badges
uh we bought we did spend quite a bit of
work trying to figure out what the
alcohol size of this matches where it's
going to make sure
transfer and
yeah it's like a key trade-off rate is
between like transferring all your data
like many times when you have high never
costs and then like loading it all on a
single thing which is going to take
really long or else you're going to run
out of memory which is
maybe I missed this but like this big
picture when you were first given this
problem they said you have to get this
done in X seconds and currently it's
taking y seconds what was that
how to where how fast did you get it how
fast was it originally
so it only took a couple days uh for
them to do this kind of work and
yeah I hope so
yes were there any like sort of really
subtle desk please like switching
between similar apis for the same
problem that we made big performance
differences so switching between uh
group the gas data frame to the gas bags
[Music]
is a lower level desk API
yeah
but I think that's guys on a lower level
supposed to be needed
thank you
[Applause]